Hello peoples of the Psych2Go comunity, my name is Matt and I'm stoked to be coming at you from my channel Das Kookie with another video.
Today we're going to be chatting about that one creepy dude in the horror movie you just watched.
Or really, I guess, just all the creepy people in horror movies. Ever.
However, this video is not going to be creepy!  So watch on as we bring up 5 facts about psychopaths brought to your by our rad writer, Sophie.
Fact 1: Psychopaths are animal driven
One of the more subtle characteristics of a psychopath is that they're animal driven.
This means that they're more concerned with basic human needs like food, water, and money according to research.
Some psychopaths may also believe in a higher power and be more spiritual, but it is more likely that they deem basic, primitive needs more important.
Fact # 2: Psychopaths lack empathy
One of the biggest symptoms of a psychopath is that they have a lack of empathy.
One interesting study, as reported by Science Daily, discovers that when psychopathic individuals imagine others in pain,
brain areas necessary for feeling empathy or concern for others fail to become active.
Furthermore, when imagining others in pain, they showed an increased response in the ventral striatum,
an area that involves pleasure.  When imagining pain to themselves, however, psychopathic participants showed a typical neural response.
Fact 3: Psychopaths are Malignment Narcissists
Nature Magazine published a fascinating article on the neuroscience of psycopaths based on a study done by a group of Dutch researchers.
They found that psychopaths displayed malignment narcissism,  which explains psychopath's ability to manipulate any situation to their own advantage
with complete disregard for the suffering their behavior might cause others.
Furthermore, some psychopaths are boastful and arrogant, and often criticize others.
And this is simply a result of their grandiose sense of self-worth.
Fact 4: Psychopaths are charming
Psychopaths are often amusing, entertaining, and witty.
As Psychology Today reports, they're effective at presenting themselves, and they are extremely likeable and charming.
The reason psychopaths are able to use their charm so powerfully is because they're able to get inside your head.
This is rather simple for them, because they have zero distractions, and intense focus.
Therefore, they're able to create the illusion of the connection that you might feel.
Fact 5: Psychopaths are pathological liars
Everybody lies, however, not everybody is a pathological liar.
This is what mental health professionals call 'pseudologia fantastica". This is considered to be one of the elements of diagnosing psychopathy.
According to mental health professionals, psychopaths not only lie about little things like what they had for dinner, but
they also lie about big things, like which college they attended.
Researchers have claimed that psychopaths lie in order to control others by manipulating them.
These have been 5 facts about psychopaths!  If you'd like more information on the topic, the link to the original article is in the description below.
Also if you'd like to see more videos like this, feel free to subscribe to this channel
and if you like to view the stuff I put out on my channel, the link to that is also in the description below.
The question of the day is: who is your favorite psychopathic villain in a movie?  Answer in the comments below.
Thank you so much for watching, and dream on, dreamers.  Peace.